[Musique]
nous vous donnons des nouvelles comme moi
J'aimerais qu'ils me parviennent sans filtres
Je veux dire, c'est ce qui s'est passé et
C'est ce dont je vais vous parler
de manière super naturelle et avec moi
pas de vocabulaire et peut-être que cela ressemble à un
un non-sens mais dans un milieu traditionnel
tu n'entendras jamais un gros mot comme
ou en argot mais mais nous le faisons
Donc je pense que cela nous donne encore plus
crédibilité que les médias
traditionnel
[Musique]
Je me souviens à la fin du contenu que
le triomphe est sur tiktok super instantané et
Je pense que les médias traditionnels
besoin de mettre à jour vers les nouveaux
des technologies telles que Twitch ou
tiktok et je pense que c'est un moyen idéal de
communiquer depuis le bombardement de
l'information est ce qui fonctionne
actuellement plus
[Musique]
Donc je dirais que ce que ça fait
l'actualité n'est pas du journalisme de mon point de vue
le point de vue serait une information pour moi
le journalisme a encore besoin d'un
document de recherche
pour contraster les sources et vérifier la
la véracité de ces sources et ce n'est pas le cas
est-ce que cette mise à jour et ce qu'elle fait est
attraper les nouvelles de l'agence et autres
médias et faire un
résumé au mieux et
t'expliquer la nouvelle
[Musique]